check us out I pulled I just I just
Google searched this The Unborn victims
of violence act yes is the United States
a law that recognizes an embryo or fetus
in utero as a legal victim if they are
injured or killed during the commission
of any of over 60 listed federal crimes
of violence the law defines Sheldon
utero as a member of the species of homo
sapiens at any stage of development the
law is codified into codified in two
sections of U.S code blah blah blah the
law applies only to certain offenses
over which the US government has
jurisdiction including certain crimes
committed on federal properties against
certain federal officials and employees
and by members of the military in
addition it covers certain crimes that
are defined by Statute as Federal
offenses wherever they occur so look to
put it simply if you kill an unborn baby
since 2004 it has been considered a
crime and the embryo is a legal victim a
person too according to what you were
saying what's the name of that again The
Unborn victims of violence act yeah that
was the Bush Administration and uh the
GOP congress's kind of foot in the door
of normalizing the idea of like you know
this is an unborn child it's it's also a
victim for future references you know
and this is also why abortion should be
banned or restricted or whatever so this
was Bush's way of of virtue of signaling
that The Unborn fetus is a is a person
not just signaling but actually creating
the the legal mechanism to to build upon
in the future the camel's nose Under the
Tent and you know a few years later you
got a full camel in your tent
um the
um uh the and the the purpose behind
that as Tim noted that's for federal
offenses or for federal Personnel like
military personnel or whatever so like
if it's outside of federal jurisdiction
that doesn't apply so the whole purpose
of that even though it's very limited
when it could ever be used the whole
purpose of that yes was to signal to the
base but also to create that that
infrastructure or that legal mechanism
to make future uh build upons in the
field this would mean that in Washington
DC for instance if you commit one of
these listed crimes against a pregnant
woman resulting in the death of the of
the of the fetus then you're you're
charged with this yeah exactly but I
guess I guess what is the charge is it
uh feticide is it homicide is it murder
manslaughter how do they how do they
handle it uh that I don't know I guess
if it's a legal victim and considered a
person it would just be homicide or
whatever they did to it like basically
whatever you did to the to the the fetus
right um they call it murder had you
done it to a you know a post-born person
whatever
um it's the same problem the title of
the bill is an act to amend Title 18 U.S
code and the uniform code of military
Justice to protect unborn children from
assault and murder and for other
purposes yeah so quite literally they
refer to it yeah if it was killed it
would be murdered right now or whatever
abortion's not part of this it's an
exception it's abortion but I could
imagine this argument happening where
they're like well abortion should be uh
considered part of The Unborn victims of
violence act so we got to be real
careful that they don't start
interweaving these without people
understanding what's happening because
if a mother goes in for an abortion and
then gets charged with murder because of
some stupid law that's gonna just
unravel the the fabric of society we've
got to not start punishing women for
this is I believe a gray area right now
because the the Roe v Wade decision uh
they decided they say sidestep the
question of is this a ninth amendment
issue where abortion is an unenumerated
right or is it a 10th Amendment issue
where this was never covered under the
Constitution and therefore it should be
left to the states of the people instead
they sidestepped and said well it's
really it's a question of privacy it's a
violation of privacy
um and so in overturning this uh the the
uh the current Supreme Court said not
only it's not a ninth it's not a privacy
issue they said it's also not a ninth
amendment issue but they said it's a
10th Amendment issue meaning it should
be left to the states so at least as it
was decided it did not sound like they
had an appetite for a federal ban on
abortion the fascinating thing to me in
all of this there was a tweet from a
personality I saw on Twitter who uh was
was wondering why he said something like
name any medical procedure where you
have no right to privacy
why isn't this a theme of blah like and
I was like did you read row
because I don't think any of these
people actually know what the point of
Roe was or the decision one of which uh
was stated by the Supreme Court the
fetus itself is a living being with a
right to privacy therefore the question
of an abortion is not about a single
person but about two persons which is
why we ended up with the trimester
um ruling was like basically they said
okay in the first trimester you can get
an abortion but afterwards now you have
to consider the person's life which is
the baby and then with Casey they said
it's a viability it's not trimester yeah
I don't think any of these people
realize that they keep saying things
like my body my choice and you're like
read row they're specifically saying at
a certain point you have to recognize
there are two bodies here yeah they
don't even they don't even recognize
that in the federal law they actually
have a photo here on the Wikipedia page
of a woman named Tracy Marciniak holding
the body of her son she was seriously
injured in an assault during the nine
month of a pregnant ninth month of her
pregnancy so that that that's what I
often say like I don't understand why
there is a legal distinction
between two babies of the exact same
amount of time since conception but one
has been removed from the womb and one
hasn't why why is there a legal
protection for one but not the other I
don't understand any logical or moral
statement
mostly because the woman still has the
protection the protections like deferred
to the mother if the baby's in the womb
but that that still doesn't fly like if
a mother was
shielding her baby from your assault and
you ended up hurting her hands and
killing the baby you still committed
homicide well like if you if a pregnant
woman goes and kills someone you don't
charge the baby with accomplice to
murder no because but it's the second
person that was there you know and doing
going through all the Motions with them
like it's an argument that you don't the
baby's not not able I'm not following
the baby the baby's not able to make
choices at that stage so you can't treat
it like why would you like kidnapping
someone while you commit crimes we don't
say the the kidnap victim is responsible
for the crime yeah so there's bringing
your child to a bank robbery we don't
hold the child responsible they're
occupying the same physical space
there's two parallel debates here one is
the personhood debate you know when it
does this cease to be a clump of cells
and when does it become a full-fledged
person that has the same legal and and
moral and ethical protections that
anyone else would have a secondary
debate is even if it has Hood at some
point before birth which I think I I
it's hard to argue that it like there's
some Magic Moment passing through the
womb like oh now it's magically a person
uh but the the secondary debate there
becomes you know at what point if ever
does one human life have the right to
the you know connection to another human
life for its uh subsistence and so that
that has been an argument that you know
the mother and that's why it comes down
to what the mother wanted or or intended
or decided is the idea well that the
mother uh shouldn't have to be you know
should the mother have to be uh you know
tied to and be providing uh you know
subsistence to and risking uh you know
her life and health for a second person
even if it is an actual you know
recognized person that does that does
that go ahead oh no I was gonna say this
is where it's interesting because if you
look at polling across the board over
the past several decades most people
you'll see the left will be like 80 of
people so are pro-choice and I'm like
yeah but they also really resent and
reject elective abortion because the
average person when you're asking about
abortion they think they imagine this
woman who's crying and being like I have
no choice you know I need to make the
right decision for my life and my family
and I wish it wasn't this way but
instead you have like 93 of abortions
are elective no reason given many women
use it as a form of contraception most
people don't like that so when you look
at I actually went through tons of data
yeah all these different polls all these
different institutions because I'm like
okay they're saying I can't believe that
most people in this country are just
like totally fine with abortionist
contraception and people keep saying
they do and it's like when you actually
look at the questions asked you realize
actually they're not okay with elective
abortion and they're very much in line
with I think how Oklahoma's been
handling it meaning
abortion is legal in any legitimate
circumstance and legitimate being a very
very narrow band of acceptable causes
for why abortion can happen yeah and
most people I think it's more than
two-thirds around 70 say abortion should
only happen with a legitimate reason and
I'm like that's actually very
restrictive that would get rid of 93 of
abortions
you're not hearing that when it comes to
what the left is actually arguing when
they're talking about this so I bring
that up because you mentioned the um
the woman is providing her body yeah
yeah to the child and this is an
important distinction in the issue of
rape and incest I actually I think you
have a very very difficult position
but in this sense it's especially I
think women have a right to abortion
particularly because
if you're going to make the argument
that women made irresponsible choices
and then got pregnant rape's not an
irresponsible choice you were right it's
a victimhood yeah and so here's the
challenge because I've argued with this
with Sheamus
if a woman says I'm gonna go party
tonight I don't need protection and then
gets pregnant
then someone makes the point the
government can't mandate she provide her
body to another being it's like well
hold on she made the choice to provide
her body to that being and now wants to
rescind it yeah it's not that she made
the choice specifically thinking it
would happen but she engaged in the
behavior which results in that it
happened and now theirs are being
dependent upon her so it's it's like
if you agree to uh a medical procedure
that would provide a direct link to
another person's blood and then after
two weeks said I want to shut this down
they'd be like well now you'd be killing
the person it's a different story as
opposed to someone forcefully jammed you
know you've fused your body with someone
else Human Centipede style right then
I'd be like you had no right to do that
and you can't hold it again but the
incest thing isn't a victimhood either
an incestors consensual disagree well
there could be rape involved in a in an
incest situation but if if a brother and
sister decide to have a baby together I
don't understand how that would be
different than having like a child with
some sort of deformity in the womb I I I
I do understand your point and I think
there is an important moral distinction
to be made that individuals can choose
to engage in that behavior but I also
think incest has a special a special
space in that it results in serious
problems it can in inbreeding they would
call it but like the soaking like that's
why it's illegal just actually yeah yeah
but so can any kind of deform like if
you find out at night or three weeks or
seven weeks that the child has like a
brain deformity or something then it's
it's basically like an ins like a like
an incest gone wrong right but also I
mean when they say the reason they say
rape and incest is very often incest is
rape it is rape within the family like
the power dynamics alone of you know a
father having sex with it and
impregnating a daughter that's rape like
I mean there's you know that's not it
would be very hard to argue especially
if you got a very young daughter or
something like that statutory rape yeah
well not just statutory but also from
the standpoint of like this is a child
like it's it's pedophilia or hemophilia
or whatever you want to call it so it's
it is also an act of of sexual assault
or rape uh in addition to the fact that
they're related so so uh that's because
uh the child can't consent the idea is
legally a child until they're 18 right
consent so it's a form of rape right if
they call it statutory you're not actual
you're making this doesn't have to find
like two consenting adults adult
siblings that have get pregnant should
they just be able to go get the baby
aborted at five months I mean it's a
good point because
um we certainly are not okay with the
idea of eugenics based abortion where
it's like I don't like the baby has I
I'm told the baby will not be well
therefore get rid of it because if the
incest is the same argument then yeah
but I I want to point something out
because um I saw a meme and it's the
it's the it's the the two arms coming
together with like two distinct ideas
and then coming together over one you
know what I'm talking about yeah and
it's a slavery and abortion and then
together it said denying personhood
rights and I was like Ah that's really
funny because it's Democrats that are
denying personal today and then I was
gonna make a joke I was like you know
who else denied personhood rights and I
was gonna put the Confederates and then
I was like wait those are the Democrats
too it's literally just the Democrats
yeah yeah I want to tell you I mean I
don't know how much longer you wanted to
talk about this so I want to I do want
to get this in I actually personally
consider myself pro-life I think that
abortions are more often than not
gruesome and regrettable things
um the reason that I really do not like
the idea of government getting involved
in this is because if you look at how
government handles things they never
just handle this
they by their very nature there's
Mission creep and they just keep getting
more and more and more involved if they
take the turn of saying this is a
constitutionally protected person inside
of your body and we have to make sure
this person is not killed that doesn't
end there it is also we need to make
sure you're taking care of this person
and if we're making sure you're taking
care of this person we need to make sure
that you're getting regular inspections
and if there's a miscarriage we're going
to have to investigate that and you know
what you're going to need to be taking
uh you know keep your vitamin levels at
a certain level and keep your BMI below
a certain level this inevitably if you
look at the history of how government
ends up regulating things this will
inevitably at some point especially once
the progressives decide that they've
lost this battle and they're just going
to fight it on the other side it will
lead to pregnancy licensing if and if
that sounds insane by the way for anyone
who thinks that sounds insane go back a
hundred years and tell someone all the
things they have to have a license to do
right now and now go forward 10 20 years
and tell someone that you could have an
unlicensed pregnancy and look at the
look of horror on their face and
whenever something has to be licensed or
regulated here come the rent-seeking
crony lobbyists who want to make sure
that their prenatal vitamin is mandated
so now what used to be eight dollars a
month is now 500 a month and who knows
if your insurance is going to cover it
and you're going to end up inevitably in
a situation because abortion illegal
abortions will always be available there
will always be a black market for it
where poor women who are unable to
afford a legal regulated pregnancy end
up getting an un getting an illegal
abortion who would have otherwise kept
the child because they can't afford the
burden of getting illegal pregnancy and
it's way easier to hide an illegal
abortion than a than an illegal notion
that anyone's miscarriage would be
investigated in the circumstance that
you know
abortion would be federally banned or
but then anyone could just say they
miscarried instead of had an abortion
Roe v Wade was the start of the
government encroaching upon women's
bodies
like that's what do you mean by that
that's the new precedent they shouldn't
have gotten involved in the first place
they're regulating pregnancy and so so
just read that one
U.S women are being jailed for having
miscarriages
now it could be wrong yeah I want to
hear the full it could be wrong right
they say 21 year old Native American
woman from Oklahoma was convicted of
manslaughter after having a miscarriage
people were outraged but she was not
alone
they say she was sentenced to four years
in prison for the first degree
manslaughter of her unborn son was she
doing drugs maybe that's what I've seen
a couple cases like this and I was like
what the heck The Examiner did not
determine the cause of death noting
genetic anomaly placenta abruption or
maternal methamphetamine use could have
been contributing factors so it was the
drug use yes but it led to an
investigation and the problem is if
you've criminalized abortion then the
easy loophole if they're not actively
investigating miscarriages is to just
say oopsie got a miscarriage right and
so that can trigger I mean it's not like
every single time they're gonna you know
have someone and they're gonna be
drilling and putting the lights on them
and all of that but at the very least
there has to be some follow-up by law
enforcement to make sure this was a
legitimate uh miscarriage now imagine
being a woman who's just had a
miscarriage I think that that is
inevitable do you think that before 1973
everyone who had a miscarriage was
getting investigated uh no actually
before 1973 and really before the
restrictions that started a few decades
prior where abortion was actually
something that was largely unregulated
in the U.S and so it wasn't really
coming into coming into the late uh 19th
and early 20th century was actually when
you saw the band starting uh I will tell
you I mean if you if you take it to a
logical conclusion because otherwise if
that's not the case then really there is
no effective ban on abortion they can
just all say they miscarry the reason
you might have seen bans on abortion
starting in the early 20th centuries
that's when contraception was taking off
but that's a whole other oh yeah yeah no
I mean there's there were reasons for
that but and the only point I'm making
is that we haven't seen this exist long
enough to see The Logical conclusion of
what happens when government gets their
their hooks into something
um you know government tends to screw
things up that's what concerns me about
the Roe v Wade overturn is that now
instead of one government involved in
the regulation there's 50 governments
regulating it I don't know that's kind
of a good thing I don't know because I
don't want the government
decentralization is better than
centralization in general sometimes you
if you argue you know decentralization
should go to the individual right
ideally so if you're arguing that this
is a woman's rights thing that the
obvious argument is that it goes back to
the individual uh if you're arguing that
there should be some regulation of this
then the argument would be that it
should be handled at the state level I'm
kind of transcending all of that and
saying I really just the idea of
government getting involved in something
like this you know the War on Drugs more
drugs empowering of cartels uh the the
the criminalization of otherwise
peaceful human behavior uh the
militarization of the police no knock
rates all of this came from trying to
regulate the use of a substance and and
if you get them now involved in
pregnancy then I'm just I'm very
concerned where that's going to lead not
not immediately but you know years
decades down the road what that leads to
especially once progressives say hey you
know what screw it we'll just regulate
the hell out of it then I hear you on
government involvement the way I have to
describe it is that people recognize a
problem and say let's do a government
program to fix it yes so you have a
wound on your arm you saw the Band-Aid
on it yeah a few months later they say
oh that wound is looking festery and
stinky let's put another Band-Aid on it
and they keep stacking up bandages on a
festering gangrenous wound they never
they never solve yeah um but that being
said the problem's cultural it is very
much one of the reasons we didn't have
the issue with abortion pre-1973 that we
do today or would is because a very
different culture
today it's like shout your abortion
abortion at nine months you get an
abortion and you get abortion Lena
Dunham coming out saying she wished she
had one even like she didn't but she she
didn't get pregnant she was saying she
wish she just got pregnant so she could
have an abortion she was like all these
women talk about and I want to talk
about it too and it's like that's messed
up that's the complete sigh up that
anyone would think so I had to say Psy
up that
um you know anyone is favorable to that
I think most people feel rather lukewarm
or have mixed feelings about abortion no
no the zombies dude that like Michelle
wolf did a whole bit where she was like
you get in a bush and yay and they're
all cheering yeah but the masses not the
Talking Heads oh for sure right right
right right I see what you're saying a
psyop yeah yeah regular that's what I
was saying most people and you'll get
the polls are like we think abortion
should only be allowed with legitimate
reasons and like that eliminates 93 it's
a much more nuanced take than either
side wants to say there's there's not
there's not this large plurality that's
like yeah even if you've been raped you
have to carry the child nor is this
large necessarily large plurality that's
like yeah all the way up to the very
moment of birth we're cool with it um
but like you said it's a cultural issue
it's also an economic issue like if you
look at the the surveys that have been
done of women that get abortions it's
largely for economic reasons a lot of
them are already mothers who have just
made an economic decision well that's a
problem that can be solved in an
economic thing I I I wish most of it was
no reason given
of reasons that are given economics is
the main one and so the point of that is
that you know I think that I wish that
there was more Focus put on addressing
the concerns and reasons why women get
abortions uh getting rid of some of
these ridiculous uh restrictions on
adoption which by the way pro-lifers
agree with I hate watching pro-choicers
or pro-abortion whatever you want to
call them on Twitter and on Facebook
going well you know if these pro-lifers
really cared they'd want to loosen the
restrictions on adoption well yeah
pro-lifers actually do want that like
they they they definitely want that they
want adoption to be easier it's it's
like what two adopted kids yeah no it's
it's it's it they absolutely want that
so that that's a a common point that we
could all agree on thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists list employed makes
this show happen and you will get access
to exclusive members only segments of
the timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there